Explosive action scenes, a sympathetic Sherlock,
and teen romance are just some of the biggest
changes the Enola Holmes movie made when adapting
the original novels.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video we're exploring 11 major differences
between the Netflix movie and Nancy Springer's
Enola Holmes book, The Case of the Missing
Marquess.
Film and book spoilers ahead, so take care.
During interviews for the movie, Henry Cavill
has spoken about how his Sherlock diverges
from what he calls
"the traditional misogynistic genius" we're
used to seeing as
"Enola softens [him] and opens up his heart."
This is very different from the way Sherlock's
portrayed in Springer's first Enola Holmes
mystery as well.
In the book, the world famous detective certainly
has a low opinion of women,
banging on about their irrationality, untrustworthiness,
the "innate untidiness" of their minds,
and even his own sister Enola's limited "cranial
capacity".
And book-Sherlock certainly never reminisces
about his memories of Enola's childhood and
her pine-cone dog Dash, as Cavill does in
the film.
Making Sherlock more openly sympathetic towards
his sister in the movie, and giving him, as
Cavill says,
"more warmth, kindness, and humanity"
"You've become quite the detective Enola."
creates a sharper contrast between him and
Mycroft than in the novel where the brothers
are pretty much as curt and imperious as each
other,
both passing plenty of judgement on Enola,
her mother, and how they live.
And, although we do see some similarities
between Sherlock and Enola in the novel,
with her even deliberating mimicking him a
few times,
the fact that in some ways they're like two
peas in a pod, as Cavill says, is emphasised
more in the film.
Sherlock even ends up wanting to be his sister's
guardian, which really accelerates the way
he grows to respect Enola which happens much
later in the series of six books.
The movie adds lots more action and intrigue
to the already very enjoyable original story.
For example, Enola and Tewksbury cross paths
in much different circumstances in the film
than in the book
where they only meet three-quarters of the
way through the story when they're kidnapped
and tied up on a boat in London before escaping
and being chased through the streets of the
capital.
In the movie, however, Tewksbury pops up much
earlier, a mere 20 minutes into the film's
2-hour run time,
when he tumbles out of a carpetbag and then
he and Enola end up being pursued by a man
trying to murder him before they make a daring
escape from a moving train.
Tewksbury's early on-screen introduction brings
the mystery of his disappearance forward in
the story and means that he and Enola spend
much more time together than in the book
where Enola travels alone to London by train
dressed as a widow rather than as a young
boy.
The film also adds masses of intrigue to Tewsbury's
tale.
In the original story, Tewky, as his mother
calls him, hates being treated like a baby
and wants to run away to sea,
so leaves for London where two men kidnap
him to get ransom money from his mum and dad,
both of whom are still alive.
Unlike the movie,
there's no big conspiracy involving his grandmother
trying to have her progressive son and grandson
murdered to prevent them from increasing voting
rights among the general population.
By adding the grandmother's scheming to the
plot,
the film raises the stakes putting Tewksbury
and Enola's life in mortal danger on several
occasions and also having the fate of the
country's progress rest in their hands.
Extra drama is also added to the story of
Enola's mother in the film.
Eudoria is described as a "free thinker [and]
a proponent of female suffrage" in the book,
but there's no gunpowder plot or any clues
to a store of explosives in Limehouse Lane.
And although Enola is attacked and kidnapped
on the streets of London, there's no attempted
drowning or literally explosive fight scene
like in the movie.
Another interesting difference is that in
the book one of Enola and Tewksbury's London
kidnappers actually plays a dual role
as he also masquerades as a female medium
who first claims she can help Tewksbury's
family find their missing son and later recommends
they pay the large ransom when the demand
arrives.
The film sees Mycroft pack Enola off to his
friend Miss Harrison's Finishing School for
Young Ladies, where she's taught how to walk,
speak, laugh, and sew, as well as to act and
think as she's told.
This is another change from the books where
there's no Miss Harrison character and Enola
never goes to boarding school.
Though book-Mycroft does arrange to send Enola
away to school to correct her wild ways,
Enola tricks everyone into thinking she's
leaving for school, then runs away to continue
her search for her missing mother instead.
Right at the start of the movie, Enola turns
to the camera and speaks directly to us in
the audience:
"Now, where to begin?"
While in the novel, she doesn't talk straight
to us readers in the same way, the story is
told from her point of view.
So the film's choice to have her break the
fourth wall throughout, giving us a running
commentary on her adventures, is a nice way
of bringing to life how the book is told through
Enola's eyes.
And characters connecting directly with their
audiences in that way is something director
Harry Bradbeer certainly has plenty of experience
with from his work on the TV series Fleabag,
where creator and star Phoebe Waller-Bridge
regularly tears down the fourth wall.
In fact, it was while watching Fleabag that
screenwriter Jack Thorne got the idea to use
that device in the movie as a way to
"get inside the mind of someone who spends
the majority of [her] time alone."
In Bradbeer's mind, the main reason to break
the fourth wall was Enola's loneliness as
that "meant that we were her only friend,
she needed to communicate with us."
A striking difference between the original
story and the film is the way the movie plays
up a blossoming romance between Enola and
Tewksbury,
who's aged up from 12 years old in the book
where there's no real hint of any such crush.
In the film, Tewksbury even knows Enola's
true identity;
whereas in the book, she deliberately never
tells him who she really is,
and he only discovers she's related to Sherlock
Holmes by accident.
Book-Enola even disappears from Tewksbury's
life without so much as a goodbye as she suddenly
has to avoid being caught by her brother.
She does "rather regret having to leave Tewky
so abruptly" and there are pointers towards
a possible friendship between the two
and little hints at their similarities like
their reasons for running away and the hard
lessons they learn about the lives of the
poor in London.
But there's nothing in the novel like Tewksbury's
invitation for Enola to live with his family,
or their parting kiss,
or any of the clear signals that they're very
much kindred spirits and that Louis Partridge's
Tewksbury will pop up again in the new film
franchise,
unlike his book counterpart who only appears
in the first story:
"You're not rid of me yet, Viscount Tewkesbury,
Marquess of Basilwether."
Enola's relationship with her mother is much
closer in the film than it is in the book.
In the movie, Enola tells us that they spent
a lot of time together and that her mum taught
her much of what she knows, including reading,
science, and sports:
"It was just the two of us, and it was wonderful."
In the book, however, while her mother encourages
her daughter's reading, drawing, and general
independence, and even taught her to ride
a bike,
Enola specifically says that "Mum and I seldom
interfered in one another's concerns."
Given the movie cast well-known actress Helena
Bonham Carter as Enola's mother though, it's
hardly surprising that the filmmakers decided
to expand on the mother-daughter relationship.
And beefing up their familial bond and their
activities together also gives Enola a backstory
that's more visually interesting than sitting
reading or wandering around the estate's grounds
alone,
which is how she tells us she spent a lot
of time in the book.
In the original story,
Enola attributes at least part of the emotional
distance between herself and her mum to the
fact she was born what she calls "indecently
late" in her mother's life,
creating "a scandal, a burden".
In fact, when Eudoria goes missing in the
novel, she's 64 years old, and Enola is 14.
At the time of filming, Bonham Carter was
53,
and while she wasn't visibly aged up to play
Eudoria,
the movie does increase Enola's age slightly,
making her 16 years old,
which is the same age as actress Millie Bobby
Brown at the film's release in 2020.
The filmmakers are very likely hoping to kick
off a franchise with this using the six books
in the series,
so it makes sense for Brown not to have to
play a very young teenager for what could
be several years as she grows up.
A significant change when it comes to the
end of the story is that there's no emotional
reunion between Enola and her mum by the final
chapter of the book.
Instead, things are left relatively up in
the air,
with Enola simply receiving a coded message
from her mum in a newspaper,
which she interprets using the language of
flowers as meaning that Eudoria is living
a contented life, "wandering, free" with Gypsies.
In stark contrast, the movie has Eudoria turn
up unexpectedly at Enola's rented room in
London to explain her absence.
"I couldn't bear...
to have this world be your future.
So I had to fight."
This somewhat teary scene wraps up the mother's
story just about enough for now and possibly
even enough for future films
if the filmmakers or Bonham Carter decide
against bringing the character back;
yet it also leaves things open enough if everyone
wants her to return:
"Thank you for your irises.
Now, if you ever...
ever need me, I'll be looking out for them."
Now, if like me, you can't wait for another
Enola Holmes film, there were some huge clues
in the movie's ending that reveal what we
can look forward to in the sequel.
Tap here to watch my full video on that or
follow the link in the video description.
So, what were your favourite moments in the
film?
And was there anything you didn't like?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to leave
a thumbs-up and subscribe for all my upcoming
videos.
Tap left to watch my next Enola Holmes video
or tap right for something else you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!